The Joe Rogan Experience International
politics scares the [ __ ] out of me with
this uh Brittany Greiner trade for that
arms dealer scares the [ __ ] out of me
man you know what's funny oh so I had
one pack I had one passive under I had
like one understanding of it where I'm
like oh
so she broke a rule
the rule seems like not that big of a
deal it's nothing but you know as my
friend Chris recently said rules his
rules so she she breaks the rule and I'm
like holy [ __ ] they're really like using
her as a political Pawn Yeah
and then they get her back with an arms
dealer trade an arms dealer and you
wonder about whether that's an
asymmetrical somehow an asymmetrical
trade but I don't know I don't know
what's going on and then you and then
you just it's kind of like oh great glad
she's back and then you and then talk
about the outrage machine then you read
like a narrative that'd be like
uh we traded
uh
International arms dealer what's his
nickname Dr Death or some [ __ ] Merchant
of death Merchant of death for a dope
smoker
we didn't get the Marine back
the person didn't want the national
anthem played at their games right and
you go like oh
there's a there's a narrative that I you
know I mean yeah there's like a
well-crafted narrative that I didn't put
together have you ever seen Russia's
take on it no oh my God it's kind of
crazy because it turned out that they
offered one or the other they offered
either Paul Whalen oh really yeah or
that's what that's what they're saying
yeah well that's what NBC was saying as
well and then they really they redacted
it and changed their story but yeah
that's Oh supposedly it was a one versus
one you could pick which one and in
Russia there there's this uh political
show sort of like a Fox News type show
where they're making see if you can find
it Jamie I'll I'll send it to you if you
do do you know what it is yeah I'm
trying to pull it up it's just not the
Link's not so the um in this uh thing
they're just completely mocking like
will he the one you know she uh he has
one thing going against him he's a man
and also you know he is white like here
meanwhile in Russia top state
propagandists reveal the narrative
they'll be pushing to harm Biden and
enrage Americans about the exchange of
Brittany Greiner for Victor bout by
falsely claiming that it wasn't Russia's
decision to oppose wieland's release as
opposed to Greiner so it's hard to say
um she this person who's saying this is
saying that uh it was Russia's decision
to oppose Whelan's release who they
think was spying
um I don't know if he was or was he may
have been may have been arrested for
Espionage but see if you can find the
video because it's going to be in
Russian so they don't have it um no but
it's um you see the um translation well
people are listening though yeah we'll
translate it he's got a great Point Joe
yeah he does
of course I was very amused but not
surprised about was exchanged for Griner
and not Whelan
first of all I can graduate about and
his entire family for many years we have
been in touch with his family and with
him personally to the extent it was
possible we communicated with him to the
extent that we could
of course this is a huge joy and relief
for all of us I can't even imagine I
can't say any more Jeremy you touched it
just go uh full screen okay but but he
was not exchanged for the heroic spy
[Music]
because he is a spy Wheeling is a spy
he was apprehended while receiving
information
on a flash drive he said he was supposed
to get photos of churches and Sergey
Pasad on a flash drive you send the
church photos to Whatsapp right that's
where we get them look where I've been
you don't uh quality would be decent no
worse than on a flash drive he's a spy
therefore to them he is a hero he's a
hero decorated Marine covered in metals
he only has one no two no three problems
his first problem is he is white second
problem is he is a man third problem he
is a heterosexual and they're laughing
this is not something that could be
forgiven today it's just a catastrophe
get here grinder beats him in every
aspect American voters were given a
choice
a hero who suffered while serving his
father land
a metal covered hero is covered who's
suffered during his service
to his Fatherland the United States or a
black lesbian hooked on drugs oh Jesus
who suffered for a vape with hashish
and well known for the sake of PR
Ison American voters are choosing the
obvious yes
I think for us it's one of one more
piece of good news first good news is
about his return the second good news is
that a nation
that spits on its Heroes to the extent
that it considers it's significantly
more important to free a rightly Charged
well-known athlete
she didn't suffer because she served her
motherland but because she could live
for 10 hours without her hashish instead
of freeing that person in prison for two
years
for serving his motherland this says a
lot about the state of this Society so
this is just like basically Fox News in
Russia there to you know it's obviously
a very propaganda driven
show but you have to that's like that's
the thing about Russia like you can't
have a show that shits all over the
government in Russia you could never
have like what an MSNBC was mocking
openly mocking Trump and you know CNN
was constantly talking about Trump and
it was jacking up the ratings that's
like not even possible in Russia yeah
you can't have a show like that the
Brewsky's be all over your ass oh yeah
laughs
yeah well you couldn't have a society
like this this is what people don't
understand when they try to impose
censorship it goes all the way through
you will eventually get to a point where
it's only state sanctioned information
that's allowed to be distributed if you
allow censorship because they've already
shown that the government is deeply
embedded in social media and they they
this is one of the things that's most
disturbing about these Revelations about
whether it's the FBI or whatever
intelligence agencies were behind
censoring certain people off of Twitter
and removing certain people off of
Twitter and removing certain narratives
and certain stories like the hunter
Biden laptop story yeah if you support
that because it fits with your ideology
ultimately you support government
control over a narrative and that is
it's going to go the other way if a
republican gets an office then you're
going to deal with a similar problem
imagine if there's imagine if instead of
100 Biden's laptop it was Donald Trump
Junior's laptop and Donald Trump
Junior's laptop he's getting foot jobs
by prostitute
um
you think they would have censored that
off holy [ __ ] do you think they would
have censored that off of Twitter and
said we can't verify the information we
don't know whether or not it's true no
it has all the earmarks of Russian
disinformation it's not a [ __ ] chance
in hell that's the problem like the
truth dies with censorship